they're here in McDonald's and we're  ordering some shamrock shakes and it's  st. Patty's Day let's go  [Music]  you gotta I've never had one I've never  even heard of one mm-hmm  your taste like a mint chocolate chip  ice cream shape it tastes like a junior  mint it's like the melty part of mint  chocolate chip ice cream like the soupy  part it's the best thing I've ever heard  my goddamn life  it's minty I don't love drinking man I'd  rather have just a vanilla shake it's  not as bad as I thought it would be but  yeah you like it it's like if you had  some spork peppermint shredded the  chocolate off and then mixed it up I  think that's exactly what it tastes like  and I don't hate it I love it actually  [Applause]  for me it's like it's a drinking gum  I am offended I am personally offended  by everyone here  [Music]